Coming off of a pretty mediocre debate performance,
Joe Biden almost immediately went to a restaurant
and made a sort of bizarre comment about a
gay waiter.
That is again just making me wonder about
Joe Biden's judgment in telling these stories
and anecdotes.
This is two days after the debate.
On Saturday, there was a fundraiser for Joe
Biden hosted by a public relations executive
in Seattle.
And Biden was, I guess trying to talk about
how far we've come as a society on gay rights.
And he said to the crowd five years ago, if
someone in Seattle made fun of a gay waiter
at a restaurant, people would have just quote,
let it go.
And people in the crowd found it really odd.
And they actually started yelling out, no,
we wouldn't have five years ago in Seattle.
We wouldn't have let someone maybe making
fun of the gay waiter, just go.
And the pool report from the event sums it
up as Biden saying basically if today someone
made a homophobic comment in Seattle to a
gay waiter, that person would not be invited
back to the restaurant.
They'd be asked to leave and would be told
not to come back.
But that five years ago you could get away
with that in Seattle.
You could get away with making fun of a gay
waiter.
So look at how far we've come.
Now.
It's a strange comment.
I get the idea, which is we've just come so
far, but the problem is that it makes Joe
Biden seem out of touch with Seattle because
Seattle has been very much on the forefront
of gay rights.
It's been very forward thinking.
So it seems kind of out of touch to suggest
that in 2014 which is pretty late in the game
for the more progressive states that making
fun of a gay waiter would be acceptable in
any sense.
So I do want to say this is a bit of a pylon
with Joe Biden.
There is a lot to criticize Joe Biden for
Joe Biden is not someone I'm interested in
voting for in the Democratic primary.
Joe Biden's debate performance wasn't good.
Joe Biden straight up said he's not for Medicare
for all.
He wants to tweak Obamacare.
There's a ton of stuff to criticize Joe Biden
about.
He has a strange history of saying positive
things about segregation as elected officials,
but overall he is actually saying the right
things about LGBT rights.
He pointed out that even though gay marriage
is now legal in 50 states, you can still get
fired over your sexual orientation in 22 states.
That's a huge issue.
It doesn't get nearly enough attention.
Joe Biden is right to bring it up and I'm
glad that he's doing it.
The comment about Seattle, it's dumb.
It shows he doesn't really know very much
about Seattle.
Seattle was way ahead on this stuff.
They passed the Fair Employment Practice Ordinance
in the early Seventies.
They've had benefits for same sex partners
for a long time in Washington state for as
long as Joe Biden has been in politics.
Maybe some of this stuff does feel relatively
recent.
Like when you've been in politics, as long
as Joe Biden, something happening in 2014
or 2004 might feel almost like the same thing.
I actually don't think we should be making
as big of a deal about this because Joe Biden
basically is right on gay rights in almost
all cases at this point in time.
Uh, there are much bigger fish to fry when
it comes to Joe Biden.
So if you believe that Joe Biden making this
comment is anything more than just being out
of touch with Seattle politics over the last
couple of decades.
I'm open to having my mind changed.
If people in the audience want to get in touch
and tell me how I'm misinterpreting it.
Out of touch, comment Joe Biden bringing up
important issues actually about gay rights
and there are far bigger criticisms that we
can and should be making about Joe Biden's
policy in other areas, including on healthcare.